ja willkommen zu einer neuen sendung von
4cast ich freue mich sehr den bitcoin
experten marcelo hier studiert zu haben
im gespräch hallo marcel ich freue mich
sehr dass du dich breite kletter ist
heute ein bisschen zur verfügung zu
stehen und zwar geht es heute um die
philosophie von bitcoin
bitcoin diesen aller munde aber ich
glaube die allerwenigsten wissen was
darunter genau zu verstehen ist mal
sinkt der kurs mal steigt er gerade ist
er so ein bisschen im sinn aber ist nur
eine frage der zeit bis er wieder steigt
darüber werden heute auch sprechen
marcel kannst du mal für unsere
zuschauerinnen und zuschauer kurz und
knackig erklären was ist eigentlich
bitcoin was hat es damit auf sich
jörg danke für die einladung also ich
finde froh dass wir das video machen ich
habe das gefühl bei bitcoin fehlt die
philosophische ebene manchmal wenn
darüber gesprochen wird in der szene
selbst ist philosophie auch ein
wesentlicher bestandteil der
auseinandersetzung deswegen freue ich
mich drauf
genau die frage was ist bitcoin ist
glaube ich einer der der einfachsten
zugleich schwierigsten fragen und vorweg
mythologisch für alle zuschauer und
zuschauerinnen
will ich so motivierend ankündigen ich
glaube meine erklärung wird jetzt nicht
den schalter umlegen bei den meisten
sondern es ist ein integrativer prozess
die leute müssen immer wieder sich damit
beschäftigen um zu verstehen was es ist
so ging es mir so geht es eigentlich
allen also man hört dass zum ersten mal
irgendwann 2017 schaut sich das zwei
jahre lang an dann vergisst man es und
taucht wieder ein und fängt alle alles
von vorne an und ich glaube das ist
super wichtig zu im hinterkopf zu
behalten
warum ein bitcoin extrem komplexe sache
ist also es ist sozusagen
klassischerweise wird es als digitales
gold oder digitales geld gesehen also
als digitale crypto währungen das ist ja
auch die bezeichnung die oft verwendet
wird dafür gibt es technische gründe
dahinter also wie es bitcoin ließ diese
digitale geld designt und und und und
und programmiert und und da ist zum
beispiel kryptographie ein wesentlicher
bestandteil und deswegen heißt es halt
rückzug währungen also kryptographie
kurz gesagt so die kunst auch zu
verschlüsseln die verschlüsselungs kunz
die verbergen kunst von griechisch
krypten also die krypta gibt es ja auch
also es hat was mit kryptisch so kennen
wir das das verborgene es hat also immer
so ein bisschen auch was leicht
mystisches oder dunkles um sich herum
und
wann wurde ungefähr bitcoin so erfunden
kann man das so sagen seit wann gibt es
das phänomen ja also
seit 2009 kann man sagen der erste also
bitcoin hat ja eine datenbank in der
alle transaktionen gespeichert sind und
diese datenbank ist dezentral das
bedeutet die ist überall auf der welt
auf tausenden millionen von computern
gespeichert gänzlich und da kann man
eben einsehen dass der erste block 2009
entstanden ist mit der ersten
transaktion der sogenannte genesis blog
da es die entstehung von bitcoin gewesen
und da hat auch diesen mythischen
charakter auf einmal bekommen weil die
person die bitcoin erfunden hat ist das
pseudonym satori nakamoto ist bis heute
unbekannt wer dieses pseudonym ist also
man weiß nicht mal ob es eine person war
oder nicht mehrere und das hat natürlich
fast schon also deswegen kann ich
verstehen dass es auch in der szene so
quasi religiöse
anhänger gibt die wie die das ganze zum
himmel loben also nur zum himmel loben
ohne krieg ich glaube es hat viele
vorteile aber eben man sollte auch
kritisch darauf gucken und genau seit
2009 gibt es der grund dafür war die
wirtschaftskrise also das ist die weit
verbreitete theorie dass sozusagen mit
dem mit dem platzen dieser
immobilienblase in den usa
der erste bitcoin mining block dann
sozusagen die chance gesehen hat und
dann war so okay jetzt jetzt starten wir
das projekt das experiment diesen
versuch eine neue digitale währung in
die welt zu setzen weil es gab davor
eben auch schon andere währungen wie
cash oder digicams es waren andere
versuche versuche sketch gibt es auch
und
das ist eben das ist eben so ein
bisschen die entstehungsgeschichte
saatchi nakamoto war aktiv online der
hat dieses bitcoin in seiner e-mail ist
er an alle möglichen leute geschickt die
mit kryptographie das zu tun hatten und
und wurde von vielen auch belächelt und
das habe ich heute auch noch mal gesehen
das kann ich einblenden in einem link
das sozusagen die technologie für
bitcoin gar nicht die beste oder neueste
war oder ist bis heute das sozusagen
gesagt motor hat sich von älteren schon
jahrzehnte alten technologischen
funktionen bedient in der digitalen
fotografie und hat bloß eine
interessante bisher unentdeckte
kombination aus allem
hergestellt und damit was so semi neues
erfunden und das ok gruppen interessant
der zug der digitalen technologie man
kann immer wieder zurückgreifen auf
vorhandene technologien und kann daraus
etwas neues machen interessant auch
finde ich dass der gründer oder die
gründerin wir wissen es ja nicht oder
die grünen da dass sie selbst auch
verborgen sind also der name ist
programm also anonymität spielt im
internet zeitalter der digitalität eine
ganz besondere rolle anonymität muss
nicht was schlechtes sein ist anonymität
oder pseudonym i tät muss man genauer
sagen man hat sich an namen bietet
vielleicht nicht der klarname der
richtige name die wird als eine art von
lebensform sichtbar in dem raum der
digitalität also das finde ich auch aus
diesem gesichtspunkt sehr sehr spannend
das heißt du schon gesagt es gibt
polarisierende wirkung von bitcoin die
einen finden es ganz toll die anderen
finden es ganz schlecht und das führt
uns jetzt glaube ich mitten hinein in
die philosophische diskussion die wir
heute
anstreben wollen vielleicht fragen wir
mal diese frage sollte geld die
möglichkeit zur anonymität gewährleisten
also wie sieht es aus mit anonymität
traditionellerweise ist er gilt ja immer
auch schon ein bisschen anonym gewesen
man hat geld vielleicht auf dem
bankkonto und hat geld im portemonnaie
aber das geld hat er die besonderheit
dass es eine virtuelle realität ist geld
ist ja direkt an den materiellen träger
gefunden wie es jetzt andere werte sind
sind geld kann man auf dem papier stück
stehen wenn wir uns darüber einig sind
dass das diesen wert hat und bitkom
denkt diesen gedanken also ein bisschen
noch weiter weil der ja gar kein papier
scheinbar ist also wie würdest du dieses
verhältnis von anonymität und bitcoin
philosophisch beschreiben was ist der
vorteil davon ja also ich mag halt immer
gerne bei problem vielleicht auch
anzufangen also
genau und bei bigpoint ist es eben
sozusagen die frage welche probleme
gehen damit einher dass zum beispiel
wenn man sich vorstellt dass alles
transparent ist und es ist nun mal so
dass man vielleicht einfach
philosophisch auf und ethisch das recht
haben sollte also normativ gesagt das
recht haben sollte auch zur privatsphäre
wie der datenschutz in deutschland
extrem streng ist und den den nutzer des
internets zu schützen versucht ist es
eben beim geld irgendwie anders
scheinbar in der in deutschland oder
auch in europa da ist eine tendenz da
sozusagen möglichst transparent die
geldflüsse einzusehen immer mit der
behauptung
mit
sonnenschutz vorgabe also mit seiner
sorge argumentation des staates ist dass
man sagt man möchte eben kriminelle
geldflüsse irgendwie besser in griff
bekommen und
jetzt jetzt neigen halt viele dazu zu
sagen bei bitcoin ist es so dass das
durch diese pseudonym i tät oder
anonymität kriminelle irgendwie so ein
planschbecken haben indem sie jetzt noch
mehr böses machen können
und es zeigt sich aber dass sozusagen
die die also bitcoin war bisher eine
gute option für kriminelle aktivitäten
weil die leute keine ahnung von der
technologie hatte nicht wussten wie man
diesen block chain durch scannt und so
aber von den qualitäten der block chain
und sowie das ganze gehandhabt ist ist
bitcoin äußerst transparent die block
chain also die diese datenbank in der
alle transaktion gespeichert sind ist
von jedem einsehbar das heißt
mittlerweile gibt es auch tools und es
wurde auch vom amerikanischen
der senat oder ich gericht ich bin mir
gerade unsicherheit da kann ich auch
noch mal eine quelle hinzufügen wurde
den usa eben bewiesen dass man von
kriminellen geld wissen wenn man weiß
wofür das geld verwendet wurde
angenommen von drogendeal in höhe von
150 milliarden euro ich weiß es nicht
dann dann dann kann man eben selbst mit
mit sämtlichen methoden die die
kriminellen so zur verfügung haben um
geldwäsche zu betreiben rückschlüsse
daraus ziehen aus dieser transparenz
qualität der bitkom lockt chain wer
dahintersteckt es ist also total dumm
als krimineller mittlerweile bitcoin zu
verwenden oder zumindest sehr
risikoreich und da haben wir halt noch
mal zurück zum bargeld zum normalen euro
da ist bargeld hat viel besser um anonym
zu bleiben und so zu sagen ich würde
behaupten
die die forderung nach transparenz ist
sozusagen gleich geblieben dass wir von
eur zu bitcoin wechselt ändert an dieser
sache nichts mehr jetzt die frage ist
okay ist ein motiv gut oder schlecht und
ich glaube es hat halt eben einen
ideellen wert dass man seine
privatsphäre schützen kann so wie beim
online surfen man seine daten nicht dass
die nicht verkauft werden sollten durch
große firmen wie facebook meter und und
und google oder amazon ist es auch finde
ich beim geld total wichtig dass wir die
option zur anonymität haben und die
option zur transparenz also ebenso eine
art freiheit in dem geldsystem dass man
entscheiden kann wann man das zeigen
möchte oder nicht wäre glaube ich
äußerst sinnvoll und bei bitcoin
hartmann hat tendenziell eher die
freiheit dazu weil es pseudonym ist das
heißt es ist ein transparent und wenn
man darauf achtet kann man praktisch
auch anonym bleiben gut also es zeigt
bitcoin macht die sache noch viel
flexibler bitkom ist das moderne geld
vielleicht die das geld der zukunft war
es schon blog chain erwähnt eine
datenbank in der alles gesichert wird
alles koordiniert wird block chain ist
ja auch ein riesenthema darüber könnte
man auch mal eine eigene sendung machen
die zab in eine frage du hast jetzt sehr
die positiven dinge hervorgehoben von
bitcoin jetzt könnte man auch sagen
dieser energieaufwand der dazu da nötig
ist um bitcoins zu erzeugen die müssen
ja auch häufig gemeint werden das könnte
auch noch ein bisschen erzählen den
prozess wie bitcoins überhaupt zustande
kommt
erzeugt das nicht sehr viel der
umweltverschmutzung also viel energie
bedarf auch in der heutigen zeit wo wir
immer so viel wie vielleicht haben oder
spart man damit vielleicht energie weil
man sagt man muss das geld nicht mehr
pressen in münzen und muss es nicht mehr
trocken auf geldscheine das ist ja alles
nur noch virtuell nicht mehr physisch
als erste frage die wir uns produziert
und zweite frage wie ist die klimabilanz
ja also dass mein lieblingsthema gerade
weil es einfach unglaublich
vielseitig ist und gerade soviel
erkenntnissen forschung ans licht kommt
bei dem ganzen thema ich möchte mich
glaube ich die antwort und drei teilen
beantworten weil die frage in rattey
beantworten weil sozusagen zu allererst
so die methodische frage so ab wann ist
denn etwas ein also energieverschwender
ich glaube da würde ich auch mit dir
gerne vielleicht mit seinem feedback
darüber reden weil fakt ist bitcoin
braucht energie wir können später reden
wie viel und so aber es braucht energie
und und jetzt wird dieses statement
gebracht naja es verbraucht aber energie
also es braucht nicht nur das verbraucht
ist eine verschwendung und da frage ich
mich okay abwanderten energie gebrauch
einen verbrauch beziehungsweise eine
verschwendung und ich glaube das kann
man da wäre die prämisse zu sagen worauf
sich alle einig sind wenn man das
überhaupt nicht dann etwas gar keinen
nutzen hat dann ist es eine
verschwendung beispiel ich gehe abends
raus spazieren und meine gesamte wohnung
leuchtet das licht obwohl es nicht
brauche so ich kann verstehen dass
sozusagen von außen viele menschen die
bitcoin noch nicht sozusagen
das thema eingetaucht sind und auch
keinen nutzen darin sehen intuitiv
erstmal sagen es eine komplette
verschwendung
so das ist so glaube ich der erste punkt
und dann ist es so dass wir bei die
genau dem zweiten schritt eigentlich
sagen naja ok wenn wir uns jetzt aber
einigen wie bitkom hat einen ganz klaren
nutzen zum beispiel eine
dezentralisierte währung zu sein die
alle auf der welt benutzen können ohne
restriktionen egal aus welcher herkunft
in welchem land es
ist irgendwie eigentlich für sehr reiche
leute auch sogar praktisch in dem sinne
dass das so zu sagen wir müssen keinen
keine lkws mit gold mehr transportieren
sondern kann halt innerhalb von wenigen
sekunden
milliarden von euros herumschieben auf
der welt für centbeträge oder eure
beträge es kostet drei euro so eine
transaktion von 50 milliarden können
also das ist möglich kann ich auch noch
mal ein beispiel verlinken
genauso wenn wenn wenn wir sehen sagen
prämisse bitcoin hatten nutzen dann dann
dann geht es darum okay dann ist ja der
energieverbrauch erst mal dass das
überhaupt energie braucht erstmal okay
aber dann im zweiten schritt könnte man
sagen wie viel und das ist jetzt glaube
ich die diskussion über die wir reden
also sozusagen ist es zu viel energie
was bitcoin verbraucht und irgendwas ist
total angemessen und ich glaube und ich
glaube da befinden wir uns gerade
evaluieren wieviel ist das eigentlich
ist ein guter punkt dass man das immer
auch so ein bisschen ärgern muss
angesichts des zwecks das heißt zu recht
darauf hingewiesen es gibt energie
vergeuden es gibt energie nutzen nutzung
und es gibt energieverbrauch und energie
vergeuden wollen wir alle nicht der
energie verbrauchte muss angemessen zu
einer nutzen und es könnte ja sein dass
leute mir schon ein das bit kommen so
viele vorteile hat dass man sagen kann
für diese vorteile muss man ein bisschen
energie eben auch ein rein investieren
auf der anderen seite könnten aussagen
durch die neue technologie die
grafikkarten und die anderen mining ins
die geräte werden immer schneller und
leistungssportler dann könnt ihr auch
die energie verbraucht zurück gehen
kannst du mal was zum einen sagen was es
damit auf sich hat man hört es immer
meinen was ist das wieso muss das
gemeint werden kann man nicht geldregen
oder geldscheine bedrucken wie wird
bitkom hergestellt ganz kurz für unsinn
zuschauer inzwischen auf jeden fall also
also genau bitcoin mining ist eine
metapher dafür wie neue bitcoins
erschaffen werden dazu noch mal basic
werk zu bitcoin es gibt
einen supply also eine menge an bitcoin
die ist fixiert auf 21 millionen
mittlerweile heute schon heute wir am 19
millionen von 21 innerhalb von 13 jahren
bekommen in der zukunft oder es aber so
sein dass sozusagen bis der 21 millionen
bitcoin geschürft wurde in
anführungsstrichen gemeint wurde vergeht
also das passiert dann wahrscheinlich so
haben leute berechnet im jahr 2000 140
so das heißt da gibt es diese dynamik
das liegt daran dass sozusagen die
meinung dass es ist eine metapher dafür
dass man sich bei der bestätigung von
transaktionen beteiligt und dafür eine
belohnung bekommt meiner sind sozusagen
die computer oder personen hinter den
computern die sich am netzwerk
beteiligen und echte energie strom das
wovon wir reden
dafür aufwenden um transaktionen in
dieser block chain zu bestätigen der
zentrale dezentrale das sind dezentrale
verfahren jeder kann teil dieses bitkom
netzwerks werden
genauso wichtiger punkt ja
genau und unsere soso alle zehn minuten
im durchschnitt dass das variiert auch
aber entsteht ein neuer block und zwar
ein blog mit allen transaktionen die in
diesem zeitraum entstanden sind so und
damit dieser blog bestätigt werden kann
ist dieses blog chain bitcoin netzwerk
bringt solche regeln mit sich dass
sozusagen alle gleichzeitig versuchen
eine mathematische aufgabe zu lösen was
total schwer ist und arbeit erfordert
energie erfordert um dann als einziger
die richtige lösung für den aktuellen
blog herauszufinden also es kann nur
einen meiner geben der diesen neuen
block heraus findet diese mathematische
lösungen löst und dann die bitcoins als
belohnung bekommt das ist dieses mailing
und und ich will noch ein paar kurze
aspekte dazu sagen weil das sozusagen
alles miteinander zusammenhängt wenn wir
jetzt so okay wir wissen jetzt bitcoin
meiner bestätigen blogs und kriegen
dafür nimmt bit konnten als belohnung
ich habe vorhin gesagt so zu sagen wir
sind bei 19 millionen bitcoins es gibt
insgesamt 1 20 millionen aber es dauert
noch total lange bis alle geschäft sind
da fragt man sich warum der grund dafür
ist das die belohnung für die männer bei
50 bitcoins angefangen hat in den ersten
vier jahren und seitdem alle vier jahre
automatisch durch den kot das bitcoins
die belohnung für meine
halbiert wird mittlerweile sind wir
nicht mehr bei 50 sondern bei 6,125
bitcoins pro block the world heißt es
und und daraus ergibt sich halt
verschiedene sachen die total wichtig
sind für die werthaltigkeit von bitcoin
zum beispiel kann man davon ausgehen das
bitcoin meiner die dezentral über auf
der welt sind und sich auch vielleicht
gar nicht kennen ein interesse daran
haben dass diese transaktionen
richtig durchgeführt werden und dass die
auch nicht betrügen also man hat ein
interesse daran dass diese datenbank der
wahrheit entspricht
warum weil so viel energie reingesteckt
wurde so viel arbeit so und deswegen
heißt das eben auch proof of work
algorithmus der dafür sorgt dass durch
diese arbeit die man reinsteckt bewiesen
wird dass man ein interesse an der
wahrheit' getreu an diesem war heizwert
der bitcoin blog chain hat und da ist
dieser unglaublich von diesen
unglaublich wertvollen funktionen und
inhalten der bitcoin york chain
enthalten weil man sich sozusagen aus
spiel theoretischer sicht sicher sein
kann dass die teilnehmer dieses
netzwerks in guten willen handeln
und das ist dann die begründung dafür
warum bitcoin so viel energie braucht
und je mehr teilnehmer des netzwerk
bekommt desto höher wird die
schwierigkeit dieser mathematischen
aufgabe und desto mehr energie muss man
rein das heißt die energie wird dafür
aufgewendet diesen standard diesen
sicherheitsstandard aufrecht zu halten
um die struktur überhaupt dieses geldes
die vertrauensbasis also die basis
letztendlich des geldes
aufrechtzuerhalten
und die basis ist ja immer verschieben
von verschiedenen gelten zum beispiel
währungen ist einmal der euro
europäische zentralbank die gibt es an
und der unterschied zum bitcoin wäre es
gibt da keine zentralbank die irgendwo
ein ort hat sondern wir alle sind wenn
wir teilt dieses blog netzwerk sind die
zentralbank ist eigentlich eine die
zentralbank könnte man sagen keine
zentralbank und das leuchtet mir sehr 1
war ja auch in zeiten der
digitalisierung alles vernetzter wird
alles flexibler wird insofern könnte man
schon sagen bit kann ist ein typisches
beispiel dieser digitalen kultur der
digitalen ökonomie die da auch entsteht
ja marcel jetzt bedanke mich vielmals
für deine ausführung du hast uns sehr
sehr viele interna hier sehr anschaulich
erklärt ich glaube wir sehen alle die
bitcoins sind ein interessantes
philosophisches phänomen einerseits
virtuelle realität sie existieren nicht
ausgedruckt aufscheinen nicht wie münzen
im metall- und sie haben auch eine
tiefere struktur die die mathematik
hineingeht wie hast du jetzt auch
erklärt und es ist eine vernetzung sind
sie wahrscheinlich die zukunft kann ist
ja nicht die einzige währung die es gibt
die einzige crypto währung vielleicht
kann es noch ein paar andere teams
nochmal erwähnen die es gerade gibt
kann ich gerne machen also ich würde nur
gerne die fragen auch zu ende
beantworten mit dieser umweltdebatte
wenn wir die zwei minuten noch
verlängern können weil genau so zu sagen
wir waren ja bei den punkt stehen
geblieben warum warum es jetzt bei
bitcoin der energieverbrauch sozusagen
so hoch und wie hoch ist da eigentlich
und kann man was eigentlich dafür tun
dass das vielleicht sogar umweltschonend
ist greenpeace hat so eine forderung
gehabt das bitcoin von proof of work weg
kommen sollte und aufruf auf steak
wechseln sollte das heißt die art wie
bitcoins
erzeugt werden und die art wie die blogs
chain transaktion bestätigt diese regel
sollte geändert werden warum das energie
effizienter verbraucht eben nicht so
viel energie weil der proof wird nicht
durch arbeit erzeugt sondern durch die
menge an geld durch den state of money
den mann hat so dass es erst mal so eine
forderung aus seiten der umweltschützer
aber ich glaube diese leute die das
video gemacht haben haben zu wenig in
die mechanismen und
konsequenzen eigentlich und vorteile von
bitcoin geschaut und basiert und jetzt
also genau jetzt zum zweiten punkt von
meinen drei punkten die basis für dieses
krimis video zum beispiel ist ein
akademisches paper was in nature
veröffentlicht wurde und der grund für
diese hochrechnungen war das zum
beispiel bitcoin so viel energie
verbraucht wie schweben wie ein ganzes
land so und dann hat sich halt gezeigt
die berechnungen die art wie das
berechnet wurde ist halt falsch also
selbst im nature magazin wo dieses paper
veröffentlicht wurde wurde es widerlegt
von 39 paper die danach entschieden sind
da wurde halt sozusagen ein bisschen
also es ist so was der punkt ist einfach
der bitcoin verbraucht viel energie aber
es verbraucht nicht so viel wie in der
sz oder new york times oft steht und es
gibt verschiedene arten wie man den
energieverbrauch berechnen kann da
müssen wir nicht reingehen aber ich will
nur sagen da sollte man blick drauf
werfen und sich überlegen so okay stimmt
es eigentlich überhaupt und jetzt können
wir uns aber abschließend darauf einigen
okay es verbraucht oder viele energie
ist das jetzt schlecht und jetzt gibt's
halt so könnten wir ein eigenes video
drüber machen diese ganze debatte von
oder ja dieser vorschlag dass man sagt
moment einmal
bitcoin mining ist die einzige das
einzige system was wir haben was energie
produktionen unabhängig vom staat
finanziell fördert
und dadurch das bitcoin so mein ding so
aufwendig ist so teuer muss man nach der
billigsten energiequelle schauen und
wenn man langfristig denkt auf fünf bis
zehn jahre dann ist die billigste
energiequelle erneuerbare energie die
und erneuerbare energien sind halt der
schritt in eine umweltschonende der welt
und deswegen ist bitcoin so
vielversprechend bei dem ziel diese
umweltziele zu erreichen ist das halt
eigentlich total vielversprechend weil
es auf einmal profitabel ist sich
solarzellen aufs dach zu klatschen auf
einmal kann man statt in 15 jahren das
teil in mindestens zehn jahren
abbezahlen und wenn der kurs steigt hat
man sich schon nach drei jahren den
osten und die aufwendungen bezahlt und
das ist so der bogen den ich spannend
wollte ist wie der umweltdebatte und
ökologische verantwortung halt raus
kommt die man hat zu ja wir sollten wir
sollten die umwelt schützen wir sollten
hier irgendwas machen aber dann doch zu
verstehen wie können wir so was wie
bitcoins nutze machen und da hat es
nicht noch mehr potenzial eigentlich das
leuchtet mir ist er ein vielen dank ich
habe da so eine vision eine
zukunftsvision
wir alle dürfen in zukunft unsere
bitcoins am rechner haben dann am auf
dem dach solarzellen und erzeugen dann
praktisch aus alternativen energien
den strom um die bitcoins zu schürfen
und wenn die sonne fleißig scheint was
sie ja durch den klimawandel mehr tut
können wir mehr bitcoins schärfen
und im winter deine wohnung noch heizen
und damit kannst du auch noch weil die
so heiß werden weil sie ja energie
brauchen wird kannst du deine wohnung
heizen damit ist auch schon bewiesen
auch für quelle hier rein kann ich auch
rein tun und und dann kannst du die
gaskosten sparen und auch die fossilen
brennstoffe gas kann man auch sich
sparen es hat sozusagen diesen
unglaublichen diese diese das ist also
das ist ein realistisches potenzial ob
wir das wirklich erreichen und ob das
wirklich profitabel ist das hängt von
vielen faktoren ab aber das potenzial
ist so es halt nicht von der hand zu
weisen ob es in enns tank von potenz in
ein akt kommt dass es hat die die
behandlung also du hast glaube jetzt
sehr gut uns gezeigt wie mit bit kommen
so viele dinge miteinander
zusammenhängen erstmal wir alle
potenziell als bitkom schürfende dann
auch der energie aspekt der natürlich
wieder auf alternative energien verweist
und auch vielleicht auf die autonomie
das heißt wir müssen nicht nur
hinsichtlich des geldes schauen wie wir
es verdient und auch hinsichtlich die
energie müssen wir vielleicht in zukunft
noch mehr verantwortung übernehmen auch
angesichts dieser energie krise die wir
gerade kriegsbedingt durchleben könnte
der bitcoins eine art katalysator sein
für ein umgang oder noch ein stärkeres
um den in richtung alternative energie
weil wir dadurch ein längerfristiger
damit dann planen können ja das leuchtet
mir sehr 1 war selig bedanke mich
vielmals für deine expertise wir hoffen
dass die zuschauerinnen und zuschauer
viele anregungen bekommen haben gerne
weiter diskutieren in der die sieben der
beschreibung unten unter der
beschreibung im forum auf
youtube vielleicht schließt man auch mal
eine sendung an könnte man noch mal ein
bisschen dezidierten thema machen aber
ich finde wir haben jetzt sehr guten
einblick bekommt man sehr vielen dank
für deine expertise dank york
das vielleicht in der nächsten folge und
mit mehr präzision oder oder auch ja
also schauen wir einfach dass wir noch
macht nimmt immer alles klar